and address oh say a safe house in Paris
why would I need a safe house
embarrassed rude things at some point go
terribly wrong it's good to have a place
to go you know for a cup of tea my
brother's my sisters
the clock is ticking fast
my dream we who live forces for last the
moment has come to take our rightful
place
in a world where we was it's funny
join me
we'll die The Wizarding of Nan visiting
worlds have been at peace for over a
century in the world wants to see that
peace destroy
you want me to hunt him down to kill him
[Music]
Damodar why can't you go I cannot let
the guys crinkles off
it has to be here
you don't suffer from motion sickness
see I don't do well on boats he'll be
fine
you know why I admire you Nick
you do not seek power you simply ask is
the thing right
[Music]
in times coming
when you have to pick a side
I don't do science
are you gonna do
I think is happening
mute you never met a monster you
couldn't love let's take it
that's her brother I think that might
have been the best moment of my life
you